recently he has to traced his family
back how far back do you think is really
far back how many decades or centuries
as far all right three centuries that's
far what else has this far
well what's far to people
I can trace back my family 100 years Max
yeah what about anybody else how far can
we go 700 years all right the year 900.
all right our next speaker is basically
Chase his family back to the year 600 CE
that's over 1400 years
so please welcome the geologically
astounding
will
my name is Will Doan I am a research
staff member with the Science and
Technology policy Institute uh you heard
from my colleague Shirley Hahn yesterday
morning at nine o'clock and you'll be
hearing from another colleague of mine
Tyler Morgan wall who's I saw in the
audience there we go Tyler will be the
next speaker after the next speaker
um
stippy was chartered by Congress in the
early 90s to support the White House
Office of Science and Technology policy
and so very often we Face challenges
dealing with qualitative data such as
having vast amounts of information no
time whatsoever to try to process it and
needing to work in isolated air gapped
systems
there are commercial tools available to
help you with qualitative document
coding I'll talk about what that is in
just a sec
um but not the kind of things we can do
in a an air gap space not the kinds of
things that make it easy for us to work
on quick turnaround sometimes the
turnaround time from the time we get
asked a question to the time we need a
response is a matter of hours
right so every few months or so for the
past five or six years I've been
thinking well maybe I could do something
with shiny that would help me with this
and that would allow me to run on my
local compute cluster in this air gap
space
I took another shot at it a few months
ago and this is where I've come up to so
what do I mean by qualitative document
coding we have textual data lots of
textual data might be academic papers it
might be transcripts it might be
automated transcripts from like YouTube
videos
anything that can be converted to text
and qualitative coding is basically
going through as we all did in high
school and college go through with your
markers of different colors to Signal
the meaning of different things we do
that and then collect the data about how
many times we Mark something one way or
another it's called coding
um we also collect the marginalia the
margin notes why did we Mark that why
did we feel that way
this is meant to be an eye chart the
only things for that are important for
us here are the big bold words so don't
try to parse the rest of that that's
okay qualitative coding two modes with
qualitative coding typically employed
um inductive where you start with a set
of codes
and then code your document according to
that code set or deductive where you
start with your documents and start
coding things that are interesting to
you and then figure out what the
Coatings and clusterings and hierarchy
of those codes are right I wanted a tool
that would support both of those
modalities I wanted to be able to
support multiple coders because me
marking up a paper doesn't mean that
what I've marked up is truth I need
other people to also Mark it up and then
have conversations with them about what
we disagree on what we agree on and so
on
I need that coding to be independent so
I when I'm coding I don't want to know
what anybody else has coded things as I
don't want them to influence me and I
don't want my codes to influence them I
want us to do it independently and then
for us to be able to compare and
contrast
we need to usually do this in an
iterative way because we won't agree
there won't be 100 integrator
reliability ever and there won't be 100
on the first pass certainly
so I did what everyone does right I
wrote an app
using shiny
I started thinking about what the
current affordances were in shiny for
something that really felt like an app
this is an about page that's built into
the app for people who are coming to it
who might not have a background in
qualitative coding to be able to ground
them in the topics that we're thinking
about
the app uh has a little sign in screen I
don't do any authentication because I
trust people on my air gapped network if
I don't they shouldn't be in my compute
space
um so the user provides their username
signs in
they get forwarded to a projects page
that shows the the projects they've
created up to that point and off to the
left they can create a new project just
by giving it a name and providing a
description
as I've done here you click add now it's
on your projects list when you select a
project from the list
it takes you to the code book for that
project if you've already established
one and if you haven't you can start
adding new codes on the left hand side
when you're adding codes you can specify
foreground and background colors so that
when we start highlighting the documents
it's actually highlighted using CSS
and it's designed in such a way that
multiple users can make use of it so
other people within my organization can
see the projects I've created and the
codes I've created so that they can
collaborate with me on the coding
efforts
there's a really simple some of these
screens are intentionally minimalist at
this point
uh the the app even though I'm working
from static screenshots here the app
works right now it's a proof of concept
it's functional but it's not pretty I
need to go make the code elegant now and
upgrade some of the the user experience
elements but a simple document upload
where you can use the HTML browse
feature to bring in uh let me think text
documents PDF Word documents Excel
documents XML documents you can bring
all of those things in it will extract
the text from those documents and turn
them into plain text documents for you
to be able to work with in the system
once you've done that there's then this
documents screen and a pull down menu
that lists the titles of all of the
documents you've brought in
when you select one of those documents
you have a scrollable text area you can
go through highlight the you know the
text just as you would imagine you would
a little box pops up
right now I coded my complete own editor
as a first pass it was good had a few
issues that I wasn't happy with I've
been looking at other Alternatives uh
the recognito JS Library seems to be an
interesting one so I've been playing
with an implementation that relies on
that this is what the recognito looks
like when you highlight something it
pops up your code book as colored tiles
based on your background and foreground
colors you have the option of putting
comments there
uh clicking the codes or notice the word
doctor there you can type in a novel tag
there so if you're doing some version of
deductive coding you think something
should be tagged but the code doesn't
exist for it yet you can enter a novel
tag there to have that element
you have the option of choosing one or
more uh coders that you want to see what
they've highlighted so pull down select
ties list in shiny you can check
multiple items there
when you do that you get a table of all
of the Coatings that they've done it's a
little
too much at the moment you don't need to
see the start and stop points of
everything but when you click an item in
the table on the right it jumps to that
part of the document when you click on a
highlight in the left it highlights that
element in the table you know a little
bit of crosstalk working back and forth
with these
there's even a regex based autocoder
built into the system right now you give
me a tag and a regular expression click
the button at the bottom to auto code
and it will go through all the documents
encode the text you might have noticed
back on the authors list one of the
authors is auto code so there's a
special author dedicated to the the auto
coding efforts
all right
at the moment uh the only analysis
that's in this as a proof of concept is
just a frequency count but it's pretty
straightforward and trivial to start
thinking about adding additional
analyzes
uh certainly we can talk about document
coverage how what percentage of the
document has been coded
we can talk about excerpt extraction
pull out all of the coded elements so
that we can then review them as a team
perhaps discuss our agreements and
disagreements
um we could do named entity recognition
based on the data that's in there any
number of intercoder reliability
assessments we can do standard Kappa
evaluation Scots Pi percent agreement
um anything at this point the data is
simply a table of data that tells me who
coded it what did they code it as in
which document starting at what
character position ending at what
character position so any kind of
statistic that I could derive from that
is fair game at this point
uh as I say currently the frequency is
already done uh trivial then to
implement term frequency analysis
relative terms uh inverse document
frequency analysis
um or to do some topic modeling on these
documents
it's built around that project idea so
different people different teams you can
come in you can create a project you can
share that project with other people you
can have multiple coders working
simultaneously in real time on whatever
your subnet is on the back end I've
coded it for two database systems right
now one is SQL Lite so you can run it as
a totally Standalone app off the network
entirely the other is as an SQL Server
so Microsoft's database offering you can
tie it into your Enterprise SQL server
and have all of your data stores
processed there
um and much to uh Jared Chagrin
that is largely the talk for today so
I'll leave you time for the uh for the
gift announcements uh this is also this
was the first screen that I created in
the application I'll just give you this
as a design principle anytime you're
creating an app the first thing on your
mind should be how do users feedback to
me
all right I want to have a way for them
to tell me what went wrong as soon as
they start looking at my app I don't
want feedback to be an afterthought or
forgotten entirely so I build the
feedback screen have it in there let
people get in touch with me
uh right now this is a proof of as I say
it's a proof of concept I've got it
hosted on a private GitHub repo
eventually I expect I'll make it uh
public and distributed as a package
um but uh if you're interested in it
feel free to use that feedback link get
in touch with me and I'll be happy to
keep you updated about progress
thank you